this week we've got Bieber challenge
boba constipation I think I heard about
this and embarrassing bags Bieber
challenge
good job either I think it's a Tom
Cruise I'm in a fight
Justin Bieber right my [ __ ] favorite
let's talk about the connection Bieber
challenged Tom Cruise to join him in the
Octagon yeah it's a real tweet I've got
a real tweet I think Justin Bieber is
going through a lot right now mentally
like he is not all there he's just gonna
be ranked he found G bass he's always
had Jesus find Jesus you want to fight
Scientology I mean he's always had Jesus
in his life but why does you want to
fight Tom Cruise after he found Jesus
all right Bart would you like to read
just let me rest we've challenging
Justin Bieber I checked Monica following
pointing down Justin Bieber I want a
challenge Tom Cruise defined in the
Octagon Tom if you don't take this fight
you're scared you will never live it
down
who's we're going to put it on put on
the fight doing a white question want
one through the core am 10 June 2019 Wow
all these people Tom Cruise right so
before like he's like a 50 something
else funny yours dunkers that'll be 60
but I bet Tom Cruise will [ __ ] them up
so you guys actually think this is
serious I don't I wanted to be serious
that's the thing yeah I wanted to be
serious too but I don't think it's
serious
I think Justin Bieber was just like high
off of something and was just that 134
a.m. and he's like what can I did you
say what is that 134 a.m. I thought you
said he found Jesus why you high on
something he didn't find you this he's
always had Jesus in his life yeah but
but medication can get you home we don't
know if this is a PR move maybe they're
gonna have a collab in a few months and
it's gonna alter his pommy
am i 10 right he's exactly dude he's
probably with this friend yeah he's
sitting there I talked to his right well
don't know he's sitting there with this
with the [ __ ] friend and they like
stoned or whatever he's like hey
wouldn't be funny if I challenged at
Hugh Hefner and then guys like I think
you have his dead he's like all older
than [ __ ] and he's like oh man Tom who's
always [ __ ] Tom Cruise's not that old
eight years old but two eight twenty
year old 25 year old right he might as
well be the [ __ ] near dead
we're dead this would hands down be like
the biggest UFC pay-per-view of all time
I wanna see it easily I want to see it I
buy four of them just to watch it once
Tom Cruise is our era and and older and
then Justin Bieber's the newer era
getting old dude who he thinks that
Bieber would win to does anyway this
song Kurt sound like a background fight
and like finally background not that I
know of but he is really well known for
doing his own stunts like he trained us
but he's a master skydiver so his like
his dedication to whatever movie he does
he goes on he goes all out so I wouldn't
be surprised even training for Mission
Impossible he learned a bunch of fight
stuff I don't know plus it's versus
Justin Bieber Doosan yeah [ __ ] got a
title yeah Conor McGregor chimed in of
course would you like to read in the
Irish accent if some Cruise is man
enough to accept this challenge
McGregor sports and entertainment will
host the bouts does crews have this I
don't have a spouse to fight like he
does in the crew at the sprouts to fight
like he does in the movies
[Laughter]
yeah so that's what Connor said some
music come out where Tom Cruise was like
uh like a high level state level high
school wrestling dude - he would already
just beat his crew seems like pretty
damn capable though and he's just
trained so much a Bieber just seems like
have you seen him run Justin Bieber can
run no no no Tom Cruise like in his
movies when he runs yeah oh it doesn't
run like movie run and Olympic run he
watched the same montage Tom Cruise
running montage no I haven't seen that
seen that [ __ ] was collateral that one
he was like oh he didn't stand so whole
movie yeah yeah look how explosive
that's in slow motion it is he runs
faster than me for [ __ ] he's breaking
slow-motion slow-motion barrier that's
real speed I guess if you're athletic
and you have like that mentality of like
I'm not gonna [ __ ] lose then you'll
win yeah I can't believe I'll keep
swinging Tywin we live in a reality
where we're actually going who would win
Justin Bieber or top crew
but we're having this come out right now
I don't think anyone really like
questions that I think we all know the
truth but I love it though I'm a
believer but I know that you believe I'm
a believer but dude I mean here's the
thing what it means that really made me
laugh
there like nobody nobody at all not one
single self-aware being in the universe
Justin Bieber - Tom Cruise square-root
should make me laugh
I love it I feel like if Justin Bieber
got jabbed he'd start crying yeah and
start hitting he would go back and write
a song about it he would call Usher yeah
it's just a matter of coming out with
the new album or something he said he
was gonna take a break from music for a
minute but then well I saw him at
Coachella ariana grande burn him out and
so I'm at Coachella lucky whoa but let
me tell you guys I was concerned because
after he finished his song and he's like
thank you so much you guys thank you so
much and she's like I ran aground it
comes back god she's like all right
thanks Justin and then he leaves because
like out he's like no but really thank
you she's doing so great for herself and
like you could tell he was like not all
there yeah and like she was like okay
huh thank you and like they literally
were like let's go because playing that
spinning bat game what's been betty was
definitional sounds like some adderall
[ __ ] yeah poor guy this dude he does
like I heard he likes to preach to his
uh
group he used to comedy sports podcast
and he did this thing tale of the tape
cruisin for a bruisin Justin Bieber Tom
Cruise and their stats
he's his net worth is five hundred and
seventy million
Tom Cruise that Justin Bieber was richer
no no oh he's been around longer well he
also produces a lot of films too so he
pays himself as an actor and uh for a
while he was the highest-paid actor
thirty million like Bieber just came in
just in [ __ ] smashed it for like ten
plus you he's one of the few actors who
still gets part of growth the growth of
movies Oh cuz he's that old yeah like
like him and I think it was Robert
Downey jr. and like that's about it I
would watch anything Tom Cruise makes I
feel like Justin we were hasn't been
doing much for the last what four years
no once his last album last year yeah
but nobody heard of it what nobody
[ __ ] heard of it uh he was killing it
get hit after hit after hit wait what's
on what's on we'd like DJ snake and then
saucer yeah or like a year and a half a
copy 15 he just a 2015
I think the Olive Garden's giant
meatball promotion had more [ __ ]
exposure 17 wouldn't you the giant
meatball tears yeah I said he featured
in but then he's been in a lot of [ __ ]
that's like CJ snake and like bottle
thing music makes as much as top two
your actors probably tap T Rock actors
and and he's also producing if your
producer plus actor dude just a few
articles ago we talked about how dj
khaled has number two album with the
hundred something thousand so think
about album sales of 100 something
thousand verses Tom Cruise [ __ ] clear
and checks mountains wide with like 500
million dollar yeah yeah cracking neck
in cash and check just as an actor I
think he was getting like 30 mil for
each movie that he was just acting in so
that's not including his production he's
still getting that for Mission
Impossible movies a Chanti well the the
residuals and everything to do Robert
Downey jr. was getting with clear in
like a hundred million for Avengers dude
he made it though [ __ ] his role in
that was a [ __ ] he reinvented Iron Man
II that was awesome he's iron it was an
Iron Man before him
no no just like the Iron Man I was like
one of the smaller slapped on no but
then when he came out you just fell in
love oh she's tight everyone's like oh
like Wolverine or whatever Iron Man was
always my dad's favorite and now
whenever he says it everyone's like yeah
well yeah everyone's Iran's everyone's
favorite he said yeah but when I was
little nobody give a [ __ ] you can't
prove it though
alright so moving on to the next story
this girl from China she hadn't been
experiencing a lot of stomach pain and
she says she hadn't pooped in five days
that's a lot of gays whoa finally like
her parents finally took her to the
doctor the doctor at the hospital they
did a CT scan and that's when they found
oh yeah it's funny cuz Bobo looks like
poop Oh Lord I without a top down is it
tugging down cuz that's her spying right
what's your middle these are the things
ghost yeah alright this girl's nasty
holy [ __ ] I mean they don't digest what
is it made out of like Chinese plastics
but they're Paul she didn't choose damn
cuz I've been drinking balding my whole
life do I got to chew yeah you too
yeah like halfway oh I feel like they're
putting fillers or something cuz that's
just tapioca that's it you know so
they're saying that it's typically made
of tapioca oh the starchy carby cassava
root yeah that's supposed to help you
share but some boba manufacturers they
use other thickeners or even
preservatives Chinese plastics wood
leads to constipation and I never been
constipated for Bulma that's good good
good cassava things like that has a lot
of fiber so that's supposed to help you
[ __ ] oh yeah but they're adding more
[ __ ] that doesn't help yeah the bonding
agents and [ __ ] like that that's you
know that's already here for sure
especially wood like how popular
rollerskating yeah for sure you know
we're gonna use some of that I wasn't
ever a bobo fan but I also like elbow it
just made it worse for me like meaning
like I just hate it even more or
wouldn't drink it because I remember
talking about a news article here on
news saying that there was open to
cockroaches found in like oh but oh
protein - that's tight it's [ __ ]
gross but somebody cockroaches get found
all kind of [ __ ] yeah but once I hear
about one specific kind of spicy I'm not
eating that in placee never liked it
anyway dude if you guys want to make
Nicki scream yeah we know just mention
cockroaches yeah even drool spit she
hates it Oh like gross like she doesn't
like caca
scream I don't mic oh hey there's a
cockroach behind yes she'll scream did
so full-blown we were all trying to
sleep at the office before the night
before our photo she could go how to get
there really early and she was like I'm
not gonna do it cuz there's a bunch of
[ __ ] cockroaches if there's no bed
I'm not doing it there are cockroaches
there's a [ __ ] in a cockroach
this is a downtown warehouse type
building I'm like how are y'all gonna
fit my tatami room yeah I was I was
hoping we weren't gonna sleep there
I only just recently got named was like
one of the most infested places yes the
homelessness problem
there's epidemics with the police
departments you like they're getting all
kinds of crazy-ass diseases why cuz I
think right so there's a homelessness
problem which means they they poop and
[ __ ] everywhere and then with that comes
like rats and then with the rats to
infiltrate the restaurants and then the
cops also have to try like you know move
some of the homeless people from here to
there and then so they're saying it's
like the recipe for like the Black
Plague all over again
oh it's a really dense place right now
la la downtown that lanes but everything
he moved out hell yeah it was getting
disgusting I'm like mmm what's the
Indian food and it's like diarrhea
oh I'm smelling the air at times so
consciously he's like an Indian food
no no I'm smelling the air and I smell
like actual food I didn't I step two
steps away and its various smell dude
that's [ __ ] crazy
those cops got to get all kinds of shots
right now it's nuts dude now you made me
hungry for Indian food by talking about
diarrhea yeah I love yes sometimes some
of those homeless people have like
rabies and [ __ ] they'll bite you why
yeah well they act like they have rabies
I think they're just on crack you gotta
check their collars if you gotta flip
them over see if they're neuter did I
see more and more tents springing up
around away boy there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on man but like why is it just
that people are not a being able to
afford living here you know I actually
recently came across an article that
they talked about how there are a lot of
Americans moving to Mexico in Tijuana
because they can't afford rent like
they're they'd rather live in Mexico
than be homeless oh I sold it why don't
they just move to like Palmdale or
Riverside what's a cheaper in Mex
there's so many others in Mexico it's
really cheap and there's there's a lot
of people who work here and then they go
home yeah so they have a fast path to go
through the border really fast and then
what else is gonna happen all those
vacant apartments and stuff they're
gonna start taxing them cuz they're just
like people could be living here but
they're just vacant yeah
yeah you just buy it and you don't live
it there's also a lot of problem with
opioids abuse and [ __ ] where we're
auction here here yeah yeah that's in
America
it's like a [ __ ] hockey stick it's
gone up like that yeah yeah if you see
like how many people die a year if you
see a graph of like people dying from
crime like like heroin or like like weed
or whatever right [ __ ] pain or just
or even good yeah we're like yeah guns
all that it's all gone yeah like meth or
whatever - right there's a graph and
basically at the very top it's like this
much is [ __ ] abusing [ __ ]
painkiller yeah all that [ __ ] sit out
here and all of it is like balance yeah
and painkillers so like for like crack
problem all that it's smooth super small
and then like pharmaceuticals people
abusing that yeah that's like the number
one yeah but that's also the least
talked about because the [ __ ] drug
companies control the media bro yeah and
they literally pay for the media and
then people or dog companies are paying
doctors to prescribe their own
medication it's kind of really scary
even like any time I've got in surgery
and they tell me like ownerless I'm like
[ __ ] I'll just deal with the pain you
know like it's not that deep dude
there's this huge [ __ ] [ __ ] going on
right now with I think it's Johnson and
Johnson or one of those farms like I
don't know don't quote me on the name
but it's in Oklahoma and they got in
trouble because the population of
Oklahoma is like really small right but
they found out that they were selling
millions of [ __ ] like drugs out there
and they're like it can't even I don't
even know how hmm to the people to
specifically their area it was it was
they found out it was being sold through
their like and it's like how how's that
even possible because it's more than the
population of Oklahoma oh dude you want
to see where how the government's just
one big unit party try to pass
legislation that says the drug companies
can't not run ads on TV anymore yeah
both houses of both sides of every party
your democrat or republican it doesn't
matter it's all joke yep well it's
really really crazy that we went from
Bobo and this girl's abdomen to we can
get there yeah we can always get this
baby I can bring it down though the
Bobo's
and her body look like anal beads kind
of see and if you go to China and you
try to get the Republicans and Democrats
they vote against Bubba they'll both go
no no way little Bubba conspiracy it
makes too much money yeah it's big
bubble over there
I love it on to our last story in Canada
there's this grocery store that have
changed their bags into these like
embarrassing plastic bags to discourage
people from Planum yeah why I need a
[ __ ] bag
not all of them it's um it's this one I
need to use bags should be having your
own reusable one [ __ ] turtle those
things are dirty pop got dirty those
things get in like five days man yes
having freedom in all kind of stuff so
the bag says into the weird adult video
important that's dope I want those bags
yeah I would go just to buy those
Doritos wort I'm in wholesale I love
those avoid the shame bring a reusable
bag that's a good bag that's not even
shameful it's not oh it's funny if there
was like a [ __ ] male orgy bag then
it's kind of like oh [ __ ] yeah if it's a
deep throat Academy or something there's
guys sucking each other off you're gonna
get in trouble because if you show this
that's like you know kids can't see this
though yeah so the other one cuz there's
three logos I don't have the other one
but it says the : care co-op I like that
one too I don't know maybe it would
embarrass normal people right and that's
always gonna say you guys are all trolls
you guys are all like no I'm honorable
sick would you carry a bag that's his
ass blasters I would not I would know
what ah she's a porn star alright like
Jesus I would go get the matching
t-shirt and hoodie with this I probably
shake your head right I'd say
congratulations right no cuz I know that
it'd be a joke you think so cuz I look
at it like oh that's hilarious she's
[ __ ] smart yeah well yeah so they also
charge five cents it's like a filter to
see who's an idiot or not it is yeah
what if you carry that bag around and
someone takes it serious yeah you know
that they're an idiot so that's why I
like it because it's a filter to see
who's in this market that's curb
who sees them who sees themselves
holding this bag they read what's on the
back and like man you don't disrespect
me man or whatever you're so boring dude
seriously yeah that for the : one some
people did find it offensive because
like people actually do go through like
colon cancer and stuff and people still
have herpes but still like no one wants
a bag that says herpes plus or some [ __ ]
and then isn't this in Canada and
everyone over there like super nice and
super like oh no we're not gonna do that
you know yeah so I guess that's the
reason why they do what gays these bags
um it's actually funny because people
really want to buy them we're normal
we're very normal we specie you're the
weird one I am weird it is what it is we
had because everyone thinks it's really
funny and it's actually it's really good
it's kind of not doing its job because
the whole point so they're saying that
once someone once someone requests oh we
can't keep up with the demands too many
bags they did the opposite now all these
[ __ ] bags are being sold exactly so
they're saying that as soon as a
customer like wants to buy one of these
bags or request it then that's when
they're they go into this conversation
about how plastic bags are bad for the
environment and there's a line of I know
they're having that conversation with
everyone yeah I would have just been
like mmhmm mmhmm can I had the bag now
they should just make the reusable bags
with that look so that's what they said
they're gonna do next because the
plastic bags is for a limited time now
because it was so popular yeah I love
how they've had they try to [ __ ] it and
teach people so bad and shame them but
it went the opposite way yeah I think
that's the best this is why instructions
and like IKEA furniture it's all
designed so that you literally can't put
it in unless you did it the right way
yeah cuz people are [ __ ] stupid I'm
one of those stupid as be right so Who
am I mmm-hmm me too my boyfriend does it
for me I [ __ ] built that [ __ ]
backwards all the time I don't want to
look at the [ __ ] pictures
listen you just need to know that I am
in your life I will build it for you
I have wiped out she loves I love that
[ __ ] I
following the rules she gets a glass of
wine just sits there and figures it out
for like eight hours yeah thank you to
come and try to help me and I'm like you
see alumnus with my happy place it's the
same [ __ ] hi this is why is it a happy
place I don't know maybe you're focusing
on binary I know there I think it's a
fun puzzle it's I care like like Lego
because we both really love brain teaser
stuff too but it's not a brain teaser
it's literally showing you the picture
no but it's kind of like a puzzle sort
of thing like you're putting it together
yeah you oh I see ice like Legos yeah oh
I see yeah when Isaac was little uh well
he was like way too young to build it I
would love getting um new LEGO sets
because I'd be sitting there forever and
he's like mom let me do a win no he
really wanted me to do it oh it's cute
you want to watch yeah you got the Legos
for you that's cute you could go buy
yourself some Legos no but they don't do
that old enough to build it himself I'm
like that's cool you could do it now but
a little part of me I was like you're
like you need help you need that's why
you need to break that [ __ ] and be like
mommy's turn [ __ ] let him build it
first I didn't [ __ ] get it and slam
it on a table with advice
[Music]
[Music]